philippe béchade bonjour alors
l'évolution sanitaire économique est
plutôt encourageante au royaume-uni
notamment grâce à une campagne de
vaccination menée tambour battant
c'est le seul facteur selon vous
on répond sur la question de la
vaccination
verlan métallique vous revendiquez
maintenant
80 % de personnes ayant reçu au moins
une dose et 71% et ont reçu une
vaccination complète alors il y a eu
fin juillet début août une petite petite
crainte qu'une petite alerte à la hausse
des cas les eaux à rien peta mais
heureusement les admissions à l'hôpital
sont demeurés extrêmement basse
comparé à l'été 2001 avant le début des
vaccinations et ça me rebondit pas et
maintenant les cas de contamination
donc là c'est suite à des tests pcr là
on a maintenant
dire une stabilisation voire un léger
reflux ce qui paraît donc tout à fait
encourageants donc
on va dire que sur le fond sanitaires
les voyants semblent au vert maintenant
sur le plan économique il ya encore
effectivement du chemin à parcourir
avant de retrouver les niveaux pré
pré crise puisque l'économie britannique
avait plongé de 19% en 2020
pour donner un ordre de comparaison en
france on était à moins 13 et demi donc
le royaume uni noah poursuivre sur le
rythme observé au second trimestre pour
revenir à ses niveaux pré crise d'ici
début 2012 bon on va dire que
globalement
la plupart des pays d'europe
espère également être revenus à des
niveaux pré pandémiques début 2022 après
le royaume uni lui espère bénéficier
d'un acquis de croissance et d'une
dynamique qui serait d'après
pricewaterhouse de +12 9% par an d'ici
2035 et même alors là on se projette
évidemment dans dans un avenir ça relève
plus de la boule de cristal que d'autres
choses mais toujours selon
pricewaterhouse
le royaume uni pourrait connaître une
croissance
de 1,9 pour cent d'ici 2050 ce qui en
ferait effectivement le pays avec la
meilleure trajectoire de croissance
sur le vieux continent est donc loin
devant les pays appartenant à la zone
euro voilà donc ces c'est une forme
peut-être de défis de la part des
conjoncturistes britannique alors en
tout cas le ministre des finances
britannique a s'est félicité justement
de ces performances
le pays le royaume uni qui est peut-être
le pays le plus rapide
en termes de taux de croissance au
deuxième trimestre en tout cas en ce qui
concerne les pays du g7 il a aussi
justifié justement ce taux peut être par
les mesures qui avaient été prises par
le gouvernement britannique concernant
l'aide à l'emploi pendant cette période
on voit qu'en france
notre économie peine un petit peu à se
remettre sur les rails est ce que
finalement
voilà le gouvernement français
a failli peut-être dans ces aides qui
était proposé aux entreprises
alors
il faut vous remettre un petit peu les
choses en perspective
le soutien britannique où le soutien
qui a été mis en oeuvre par le
gouvernement français sont assez
comparables en termes
de compensations de chiffre d'affaires
perdu maintenant il ya deux choses c'est
parce que les pays donc pas exactement
la même culture économique donc on voit
qu'en france tout a été visé une
nouvelle fois sur des mesures de
jacobine
on est dans un état centralisateur
au royaume uni on may ont misé davantage
sur l'initiative individuelle et le
royaume uni espère beaucoup
donné sa croissance en attirant par
exemple des entreprises étrangères je ne
vois pas où on va dire le même effort
consenti du côté français je donne un
petit exemple pour ans les choses
extrêmement concrètes si vous voulez
aujourd'hui créer une entreprise
immatriculée dans le royaume uni il va
vous en coûter un peu moins de 1000
livres autrement dit autour de 1200
euros moyennant quoi vous savez accès à
un package ou voulu créer votre votre
entreprise entrons en quelques clics
vous allez bénéficier d'un hébergement
d'une assistance juridique
la gestion administrative du courrier
pendant un an
donc la fourniture d'un numéro de
résistance du résidence fiscale plus
l'ouverture de comptes bancaires alors
soit une banque classique soit une fine
tech et des comptes multi devises donc
pour des investisseurs internationaux
évidemment ça ce genre de mesures très
concrètes ça parle sans sans oublier que
la fiscalité des entreprises or en ligne
unique est quand même plus favorable
qu'elle peut l'être en france voilà donc
ce sont vraiment deux modèles je ne dis
pas qu'il faut adopter 100 % l'an 100%
l'un ou rajouter vous rejetez 100%
l'autre mais en tout cas
le royaume uni mise sur une jeune
clientèle de créateurs d'entreprises
étrangères alors qu'en france on essaye
simplement de faire survivre celle qui
pâtissent des mesures administratives
voilà donc ce sont vraiment un petit peu
deux philosophies différentes
maintenant l'avenir nous dira si avec
les futurs variant side et des
fermetures administratives ou des
mesures de restriction non pas dire
coupe un petit peu
l'élan de la reprise là aussi je dirais
qu'au royaume uni il semble qu'ils aient
une ferme volonté de ne pas refermer
l'économie voilà on est de ne pas
réintroduire de mesures de restrictions
sanitaires donc ça ça paraît assez clair
et je dois dire que pour
asseoir une croissance qu'il faut
également que le pays propose de la
volatilité de la période de la
visibilité et il ne faut pas qu'il y ait
de volatilité dans le discours officiel
c'est à dire comme on dit une semaine
noire la suivante merci beaucoup en tout
cas philippe béchade d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la bourse au
quotidien etc